i've known obviously this weekend i was
gonna
say what i'm going to say but it still
doesn't make it easier
um i it's been a crazy year obviously
for all of us
and i've been so grateful that i'm able
to stay here in london
and do the show but i
can't see for me the foreseeable future
of traveling back
at the moment and have decided
that at the end of december this will
probably be my last time
on the show in this capacity as a host
um it has been this is
one of the hardest decisions in the
world because i wish i hated one of you
but i don't
i wish i hated someone on the set i wish
it would just make it so much easier to
blame this because
this i have had the most beautiful
experience i've grown as a woman as a
person i've said it once i'll say it
again
i never thought that being on a talk
show
would be this much of an opening of
my spirit soul personality
everything sitting on stage with all you
women has been
the best thing ever i love you guys so
i truly love you and when people ask me
like how are you
how's your relationship i'm like i love
these women
for real love not bs not pr
this is real and it's
hard i love everyone
that everyone that's watching this right
now you see us
but there are tons of amazing people who
make us come to you
everybody the whole crew our producers
everyone who does the sets everyone who
hair makeup for all of us all of our
editors cameramen
are everyone and i know i'm forgetting
some departments but i'm gonna
i miss you and i love you and i'm
thankful um
i am all the hashtags bless grateful
you know lucky i'm all the hashtags and
it's real
and but god this is hard it's horrible
but eve okay didn't what's the dude name
would that run uh
england what's the name charles no bar
him that's
that's future king the king chorus yeah
right then he he just shut everything
down we're on another lockdown
okay on another lockdown from thursday
and that's another reason why like
obviously staying home has been such a
blessing because
my husband and i got to know each other
in another in a different way a
beautiful way
so i want to be closer to him i want to
concentrate on expanding our family
being with my family and
oh i want to hug
[Applause]
well here's the thing uh i want to be an
additional auntie i'm already auntie to
the other baby yes
they always come to me when they come
here and go auntie cheryl we'd like to
sw
yes and they always ask about all of you
ladies
they know how happy i am there yeah it
is this is a really
horrible decision like i wish like i
said i hated somebody but
i don't it's just you know what it's
unbelievable that
i'm english and i yeah i know of my home
yeah you're american i know i love
england so
much and i listen i get it because
people who you know your husband it's
like
yes i get it yeah but
yeah it just i think over the years i've
made
i've been very good at being in busy
and being business business business and
making decisions to make
but honestly it's like you life is about
choices
isn't it and it's like at some point you
have to choose
what makes you happy what's right for
your family right yeah what's right for
you and it's
you know and it's like you know and
that's what makes this so bittersweet
we this is what makes this so
bittersweet is because we want the best
for you as well we know that listen we
just saw sarah
come back aisha you know you can come
home again
yes and that's what i hope y'all better
not lock the
[Music]
do you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
call my friends
on um the ladies the ladies um
what is that what is it oh oh my gosh
loose women i'm gonna call my ladies
yeah yeah a little swimming
and you've gotta go there okay oh my god
could you imagine that it's gonna be so
funny
i will call them i love them i watch
them every morning anyway
well i will call the ladies okay because
we're gonna network
yeah and it's a time zone yeah i want
the world to really know
that this is what it looks like when
people really love you
and understand the choices you have to
make your family it's a different time
zone
you know different situations but you've
always been a trooper you've always done
everything that was needed of you we
love you we support
you and we can't wait to see the next
chapter i just love
to see i'm like looking at you
and the way that you have grown to be
so open yes oh
you ladies help me though you helped me
you honestly being around all of you has
helped me find these parts of myself the
more honest parts of myself the more
vulnerable parts of myself
the more just everything literally you
i've
never ever had this of course i have
amazing friends and beautiful friends
but i've never
had in this type of environment where
you think it's work
this is not work no it's like it's a
place we come
that we really do we are so lucky for
real and and people don't
get that we are so lucky and i i'm just
an end i have to say thank you to you
ladies because when i told you
you know i've been dealing with this
decision
i was so i breathed a sigh of fresh air
because i was like
you guys support me so much
it was oh you just made it easier
because i felt horrible i was like god i
feel like i'm letting people down i feel
like
whatever and you guys are like no no no
go live your life real friends
oh no our hearts are like sad
sad sad and we keep looking at you every
day and we're like i just wish you were
here
so i will hug you yeah and yeah yeah
yeah
getting back for a big old party to wish
you the
best oh speaking of party sharing what
we got a plan for her birthday
birthday that's right i'm not leaving
for my birthday
everything strippers animals everything
yeah
okay yes everything oh it's gonna be
good
you're not leaving yet right you're not
i'm not leaving yet i am here
i am here till december i am not leaving
that's right
i am not we don't want you to go
anywhere just yet but we are happy for
you making such a
long choice we love you thank you you
are always here right
group
[Applause]
i love and respect you
always always and there is a big
place here for you always in my heart i
love you thank you
i love you i love you i love you we love
you i love you too
i love you i just want you to
be happy yeah yeah thank you
and hurry up so i can be an auntie yeah
yeah
we're trying we're working on it we're
working on it